l'annoncé a été confirmée ce mardi soir
aux alentours de 20h par la chancelière
angela merkel je citerai document de la
commission sur les vaccins sur la base
des preuves actuellement disponibles
mais encore limitée et compte tenu de la
situation de la penderie de la
commission des vaccins recommande
l'utilisation du vaccin astrazeneca
covin 19 pour les personnes âgées de
plus de 60 ans en d'autres termes
l'allemagne restreint usage du vaccin
suédo britannique pour les moins de 60
ans une décision qui fait suite à 31
signalements de cas graves dont 9
mortels de formation de caillot sanguin
au cerveau survenus chez des personnes
ayant reçu le vaccin sera donné qu'à
presque tous les cas concernent des
femmes jeunes ou d'âge moyen entre 4 et
16 jours après la vaccination pour les
moins de 60 ans ayant déjà reçu une
première dose
le choix leur ai laissé soit se faire
injecter la deuxième dose soit attend
les recommandations de la commission
vaccinale prévue fin avril
une décision loin de convaincre les
allemands
si vous regardez les effets secondaires
ils sont très rares si vous lisez les
contre indications de l'aspirine de
l'ibuprofène ou d'un autre médicament
vous verrez qu'ils ont des effets
secondaires beaucoup plus grave est que
nous les avale ont plus ou moins
quotidiennement
je pense donc qu'ils sont un peu trop
prudent
je comprends tout à fait que l'on soit
prudent et je comprends aussi que l'on
ne veuille pas aller trop vite ou
décider de manière trop zélé mais le
problème en arrêtant les vaccinations
tout le temps c'est que nous
n'avancerons pas et nous sommes très en
retard sur sa par rapport au reste du
monde
c'est très décevant car nous ne pouvons
rien faire et les vaccinations sont la
seule chose sur laquelle nous comptons
du moins pour mes amis et ma famille et
ça craint quand on les arrête
le gouvernement allemand maintient
toutefois son objectif de proposer une
vaccination contre le kobe 19 à sa
population adulte
ici la fin de l'été si les promesses de
livraison sont tenus et que tous les
vaccins reçoivent leur approbation comme
prévu précise le ministre de la santé
jusqu'à présent 11 % de la population
allemande a déjà reçu une première dose
de vaccin